This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode.
Today's episode, though, you may have already noticed, is a rerun. So over the next two weeks, I am putting out some of my best episodes from the last four years of almost, non-stop podcasting as I just take some time away to launch my debut book, Person in Progress, A Roadmap to the Psychology of Your 20s. Do not fret, I will be back on the 29th of April, but I just wanted to give my book a little bit of extra love these next two weeks because it's a big deal and I'm not going to talk about it too much. I'm sure you're just here to listen to the podcast and probably sick of me talking about it,
but I just want to say thank you. I want to say a huge thank you for allowing me to write this book. book and put it out in the world. This is only possible because of you all, because of you guys, the listeners. That's it. That's the only reason I'm able to do this. And I wanted to be an author since I was five, 20 years later. You guys made that happen for me.
So just thank you. Thank you so much. I would obviously love it if you could pre-order it, buy it, gift it to a friend. But you've already done so much. And I just feel honored to have had this opportunity. most of all I'm just really pumped for you guys to read it. I hope that you learn something. I'm sure if you love the podcast, you will love person in progress as well, but it's a really exciting time. And the main feeling I have right now is one of gratitude. So thank you so much. Without further ado,
I hope you enjoy this rerun of one of my favorite all-time episodes. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show, welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, whatever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today I'm going to cut straight to it. Let's talk about self-doubt. Let's talk about the negative beliefs that we all kind of have about ourselves that we carry through life, whether we are aware of it or not. Doubts about our worth,
doubts about our talent, how deserving we are, our intelligence, just a couple, just to name a few, all of which end up really restricting our potential and they manifest in indecisiveness, in procrastination, self-sabotage and disappointment. I think it's a really rude awakening when you realize that so often the person who secretly is holding us back from so many of our visions and our dreams about the future and about our lives is us. The person who is saying no is us. The person rejecting us without ever giving us a chance is, you guessed it, ourselves. It's not always conscious, nor is it our fault. From a very early age, we get implanted with these false ideas of what makes us worthy and what we deserve, whether it's from our families, our childhood environment,
our peers, myths that society tells us about who gets to be successful and praised versus who doesn't, even some of the setbacks and failures that we experience pretty early on that really stay with us. And these experiences become those false beliefs within us, that in turn create a core part of our self-concept and our self-worth. And it kind of sets up this weird cycle where in order to disperse those beliefs, we have to try harder, push ourselves harder, be something that we're not, and that inevitably most of the time doesn't end up working. If we are never made aware of that, it can really end up putting a ceiling on our potential
and kind of disrupting our compass, disrupting the trust that we have on ourselves. I know this from my own experience as a teenager and very much into my early 20s. I was so uncomfortable with who I was. I doubted about nearly every single thing that I did from, you know, my academics to my romantic life, to my, like, creativity, to my friendships. And so I really stopped myself from ever putting myself out there. Before I'd even begun, I was already telling myself that I was going to fail. And it, you know, went right to the top in terms of big,
decisions like not applying for jobs that I may have gotten, not applying for scholarships that I may have gotten, not taking risks, but also small decisions like what would I wear to class? Who would I speak to? And I look back at that chapter with so much, I think sadness, but also empathy for that version of me who was just crippled by self-doubt and spoke so negatively about themselves, was so obsessed with being perfect, never believed that she would be. But in the last decade. I don't want to say that I've been on a journey because that sounds so mystical and religious, but in many ways I have. This journey of realizing that life is short, the world is so big. People are so swept up in themselves that no one is making the rules.
No one is saying you can't more than you. And when you realize that, when you realize that you're in your own way, is when you really get the chance to reinvent yourself and reinvent your life and actually do things that take courage that you're genuinely proud of and actually listen to your intuition. So that is exactly what I want to talk about today when I want to hopefully teach you today how to silence yourself doubt. We're going to discuss the origins of those negative false beliefs, how it shows up in, you know, very invisible ways, why it can create a self-fulfilling prophecy. But above all else, how we can leverage the psychology, the science, our knowledge about how we motivate ourselves versus how we handicap ourselves to really push
beyond our limiting beliefs. We have so much to discuss today. This episode has been on my mind for a long time. So I'm excited to share it and hopefully show you what has helped me, help you learn from this as well. So without further ado, let's get into the psychology behind why we doubt ourselves and how to silence those false beliefs. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical
and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist,
Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, iHeartRadio app search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's,
correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud, charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When we say that we are struggling with self-doubt, that could mean a few things. Perhaps it's that you feel really unqualified at your job or at school. You doubt the position you're in. Maybe you're in a leadership role. Maybe you're not. You feel insecure about your appearance. You doubt whether anyone will ever find you. you attractive. You doubt yourself when you speak up, when you contribute, when you interact with others. Maybe you compensate for that by seeking constant reassurance. When it comes to making a decision about your future or even small, everyday decisions, you might procrastinate, not because you're lazy, not because you're indecisive, because you aren't confident in your ability to choose correctly. This list could go on. Basically, it's not feeling good enough, not feeling
worthy enough, hesitating to start something new because you might not be perfect from the get-go. Imposter syndrome, we're going to get to that later. All of these individual experiences are what make up what we would call self-doubt. What it all boils down to is a lack or a loss of trust in yourself and your own abilities. Each of us has this internal compass that not only guides us but is guided by our deeply rooted beliefs about our value. And that value is what gives us confidence to forge ahead, confidence to believe in what we're doing, confidence to hold ourselves highly. When we experience overwhelming self-doubt, it indicates that that compass is broken. It's starting between north and south.
And that's what doubt is at the end of the day in decision. You know, one moment I'm worthy, the next moment, no, I'm not. I'm talented. No, I'm not. I should choose a path or maybe I should choose path A, no path B, I'm not sure. And this compass doesn't get broken on its own. No one is born doubting themselves. If you are around children, you will see as soon as they can start crawling how they dart forward or they climb any surface and they never realize that they can fall and they have this uncontrollable desire to be curious and to explore and to experiment. They never once question their instincts. As we gain greater self-awareness, though, obviously, sometimes our doubts are for our own good, but also external forces begin to intrude and they
begin to cause us to question ourselves, starting with what always tends to be our main culprit, which is our parents and our childhood environment. I know it sounds really, really obvious to say, but our early childhood years are so formative. Our brain is like this big sponge, this big canvas that is taking in everything that is thrown at it, whether that is positive or not. And there are, of course, some experiences that are more significant, especially when they relate to the bond that we share with our primary caregiver because we are, you know, biologically and naturally attuned to pay closer attention to those in which we have a secure or maybe insecure attachment to.
So excessive parental criticism, for one, can cause us to really doubt ourselves from quite an early age. If you have a parent, if you still have a parent who is overly critical of you, nothing is good enough, you disappoint them, you annoy them, you don't live up to their expectations, and they let you know that beyond just kind guidance through scolding, never giving you praise even when you try your hardest to do what they want, you end up thinking, you know, if this person doesn't love me for what I'm trying to do, am I even worthy of love? Can I even trust myself? I want to please them so much, but I don't know how, even when I try. This causes us to really second guess everything, because we become afraid of misstepping,
and we begin to internalize the lack of support or the words that they say, and the seeds of self-doubt are really kind of sewn at that moment. This can also emerge when we are compared to siblings, for example, and we, again, internalize a belief that compared to, them compared to this rivalry that is set up between us, we will never measure up. We will never be good enough for our parents. They will always have a favorite. And that favorite will never be us. And that again creates self-doubt. The final example I'll give of this, which kind of underlines all of the previous examples, but it's basically when there are these
high expectations that we can never meet. And it's not that when we don't meet them, we're still met with love. When we don't meet them, we are perhaps met with criticism, neglect, punishment, some kind of, I don't know, behavior or like discipline that actually undermines who we are. And our sense of value does begin to weaken in response to that. In fact, according to research by the University of Nevada, a big factor that actually contributes to imposter syndrome later in life is hypercritical people. parents, hypercritical parents who, no matter what you did, the accolades, the achievements, fawning, trying so hard to please them, it was never good enough. And so once again,
your compass loses direction. That is one set of experiences that contributes to a very innate lack of belief in ourselves. But it's not just our parents. It's our peers that obviously also make up a big part of that early environment. And you know what? I don't think our peers enough credit for some of the pain that they cause, if we can even call it credit. Next to our parents, our peers are like the biggest influence and their influence is sometimes A, not positive, but B, just tends to increase the order we get when we get into our teen years. The people that we are mainly concerned with impressing are our friends.
The way that I could go on about the impact of childhood bullying on adult self-esteem, this episode would be hours long because it's not spoken. about. We often tend to think of, you know, once we leave that environment, once we leave school behind, once we leave our bullies behind, oh my gosh, we can kind of wash our hands of this, we're done, we can move forward. All of those negative emotional reactions disappear. But if you went through that 10, 15 years ago during that really, really vulnerable period that we all go through, you know, during that really formative period, it's not like those experiences of being bullied, of being excluded, of being, you know, socially, physically,
verbally, I don't like the term abuse, but yeah, bullied. Those experiences don't necessarily go away. And, you know, 15 years on, you might still hear those voices in your head when you're trying something new or when you're going for a promotion at work, when you're trying to push beyond your own limits and extend yourself because those voices would, just so loud during a time when your self-concept was being formed. You know, being bullied, whether that is physical or verbal or social or, you know, exclusion, that has been shown to quite literally change the brain due to an increased exposure to the stress hormone cortisol during that period, during our adolescence, where our neurons are wiring
and rewiring quite rapidly. What that basically means is that the brain of someone who, who was bullied versus the brain of someone who wasn't, are going to look very different, specifically in the regions that process danger in our environment, specifically in our emotional brain circuits like the amygdala that processes fear, and the areas of our brain that process a specific kind of pain, called social pain,
the pain that follows experiences of rejection, of loss, of ostracism. when they looked at the long-term consequences of this, people bullied as children showed heightened levels of social anxiety, heightened levels of perfectionism, and of course, self-doubt. During that time, I think we can all kind of remember this. We really, really care about what others think about us. We really care about whether we have enough friends. We really care about what the cool girl, a cool guy, like, whether they think that we're all so cool. Like it's just this constant social anxiety that is buzzing below the surface. And when people around you drill away at your confidence, whether that is teasing, whether that is,
you know, criticizing you, whether that is slight comments about your grades, your clothes, you lose that innate trust you have in yourself and you lose that kind of innate trust you have in your value and you withdraw. You shelter yourself away from potentially being hurt again or being. bruised again by these same people or these same experiences. And the way that you shelter yourself is by no longer showing up, by no longer putting yourself out there because what this has taught you is that when you do that, you open yourself up to the potential to be hurt, to the potential to be excluded or isolated or criticized. And you don't want to endure that. It's painful. So the easiest
way to not endure that is to not ever put yourself out there. This is because I think one aspect of self-doubt we haven't spoken on yet is that it really is a form of self-protection. It is a psychological defense mechanism because it shields us from potentially negative outcomes or emotional pain by being extremely cautious, by asking us to double check, by asking us to play it safe and to keep ourselves in a place of comfort rather than discomfort. You know, kids are so cruel and it's quite sad to think that despite all of us being so young at the time, we were capable of doing this, you know, semi-long-term damage to how we see ourselves and the world because of that childhood cruelty. And the impact that this has on our self-doubt
is definitely heightened when you already have innate personality traits like perfectionism, or you're a sensitive soul, or you have a high baseline level for anxiety. You know, if you are a sensitive kid, I'll go back to that example like I was. Like I'm sure many of us were, these things can be incredibly hard to forget, and also our memory is often more attuned to negative experiences we have a negativity bias. So if you're still feeling like you're reliving the trauma from a childhood bully or a teenage bully, I honestly think that that is quite a valid thing for you to be experiencing. I think that those experiences don't disappear as fast as most people would lead us to believe. Another thing that really causes us to get buried in self-doubt,
especially the older we get, especially when we are in our late teenage years, early 20s, are toxic or chaotic relationships. When it comes to love, I know it sounds so obvious, but, you know, that is where we are most vulnerable. And so when we trust somebody or when we really want them to return our attention and our affection and that turns around and becomes insults or they reject us or they treat us like, we're too much that we're second best, that does some real emotional damage. And we talked about this on last week's episode on Red Flags. There was a 2019 study that we referenced that showed how negative romantic experiences play a role in the development of our sense of self-esteem.
And our self-esteem is a primary contributing factor to our sense of self-doubt. This makes a lot of sense for anyone who has unfortunately had an experience with someone you cared about or who you liked has been the same person to break down your confidence, you really end up losing trust in yourself because you feel like, how could I have been so wrong about someone? Even though it's not your fault, it all comes back to, wait, this was a choice for me. I chose someone who was going to maybe treat me like this or what if what they're saying is true. If I really like them, there must be something good about them.
They must know something about me that I don't. So it's those early romantic relationships, even our recent romantic relationships that can once again really furrow into our brain and make us doubt almost everything that we choose to do. Beyond that, we also have experiences of failure and of setbacks. And, you know, our 20s are right for them because it is definitely one of the first times. It is the first time that we are truly independent. And we don't have the safety net of our parents or our teachers or of school to catch us. So our moves, our behaviors, they're all our own. And sometimes it just doesn't go our way.
And that causes us to retreat and doubt the compass. There will be times in which we did our best. We did what we thought was right. And it did not go according to plan. We all have them. I remember a few instances like this. One was when I went for this scholarship at my university. Thought I did great, didn't get it, got knocked back.
And that was something that I ended up being really grateful for. But that's a story for another time. And another example I was thinking of was when I worked really hard on this assignment. And it was like one of my first assignments at uni and I got a 55%. That is a small setback in the scheme of things. I could not tell you what the paper was about. I could not tell you the opening sentence. I could not tell you like anything to do with that paper.
But I remember that I got that grade. And that grade made me question everything about who I thought I was. I thought that I was smart. I thought that, you know, that I was ambitious. I thought that I was adaptable and this kind of proved me otherwise. And how could I trust my judgment now? It really didn't help that I was in this competitive atmosphere. Everyone seemed to be doing so well.
Everyone was succeeding. It was just me who couldn't keep up. And I wanted to kind of prove that I deserve to be there. And obviously in my mind, when I got that 55%, I proved the opposite. I proved to myself that I did not deserve to be there. In the months after that, I remember actually this really specific instance of writing this other essay and going back and forth and back and forth on the opening line, almost feeling like I was going to cry, feeling paralyzed by this paper. Like, is this good? I think it is. I think this is
good. But how can I tell? Because I thought that my last paper was good and I was wrong. And this leads back to imposter syndrome. You want to know something really ironic but also quite funny. I find funny at least. My very first episode of this podcast was on imposter syndrome. That was over three years ago. And I don't think I have gotten any better at dealing with it despite all the years of work that I've done. Imposter syndrome is rooted in a lot of that doubt that comes from a lot of those really core memories and core experiences and no matter how much you prove to yourself that you deserve your successes, your achievements, no matter how far you push yourself, how much you do, how much you achieve. You are constantly followed by this fear that one day, the people around you or the
people that matter are going to realize that you are a fraud. You are waiting for this other shoe to drop despite the fact that you are probably really accomplished and really deserving, but because you don't trust your own assessments. You can have all the evidence in the world, all the praise, all the promotions, everything, and you will still feel like you tricked somebody. You will still feel like somebody made a mistake or you just got lucky. The problem with imposter syndrome is that the experience of doing well at something does not change your beliefs. That thought still nags in the back of your head, you know, what gives me the right to be here?
The more you accomplish, you know, the more you actually feel like a fraud, the more you feel like you've tricked even more people. It's as though you can't internalize your experience of success. At the end of the day, it's self-doubt. It's never feeling good enough. It's never feeling like you have the right to be where you are. That imposter syndrome can push us to one end of the spectrum where we are so focused on overachieving and pushing ourselves harder and harder that we end up burning out.
We end up not being able to achieve anything that we want to because we are so exhausted. and on the other hand, it can also push us to the other end of the spectrum where we self-sabotage or we self-handicap. There is this quote that perfectly summarizes this for me. People never rise above the opinions of themselves. That is so harsh, but it is so true and it is exactly what I mean by self-handicapping and self-sabotaging. If your opinion is that you are undeserving, that you don't know what you're doing,
我们最终精疲力竭，以至于无法实现任何我们想要的目标。另一方面，它也可能把我们推向另一个极端，让我们自我破坏或自我设障。有一句名言完美地总结了这一点：“人们永远无法超越他们对自己的看法。”这话虽然很残酷，但却无比真实，这正是我所说的自我设障和自我破坏。如果你认为自己不配，认为自己不知道自己在做什么，
you are out of place, people know you're a fraud, you're not good enough, the list goes on, when the chance comes for you to prove otherwise and to step into a version of you that shows yourself that those beliefs are wrong, it is so uncomfortable, and it contradicts so many of your beliefs that you self-handicap. Self-handicapping is a behavioral response to feeling uncertain about our abilities, where we unconsciously find an outside source to blame for our behaviours that protect us from feeling inadequate. You know, if you're already going to fail, why not fail on your own terms to avoid the embarrassment of putting yourself out there?
你格格不入，别人都知道你是个骗子，你不够优秀，诸如此类。当有机会证明并非如此，并让你蜕变成一个向自己证明那些信念是错误的人时，你会感到无比的痛苦，这与你的许多信念相悖，以至于你开始自我设障。自我设障是对我们能力感到不确定时的一种行为反应，我们会在潜意识里寻找外部原因来为自己的行为开脱，从而保护自己免受无能感的影响。你知道的，如果你注定要失败，为什么不按自己的方式去失败，以此来避免将自己置于聚光灯下的尴尬呢？
Why apply for that job you are objectively are perfect for if you believe you're going to be rejected? Why post that photo or put yourself out there online if you know people are already going to laugh at it? Why ask that person on a date when you know they'll say no? why not just save yourself the awkwardness? You know, it shows up in so many ways. Hopefully you get what I'm getting at.
如果你坚信自己会被拒绝，为什么还要去申请那份你客观上完美契合的工作呢？如果你知道别人会对它冷嘲热讽，为什么还要在网上发布那张照片或展示自己呢？当你明知对方会拒绝时，为什么还要约人出去呢？为什么不给自己省点尴尬呢？你知道的，这在方方面面都有所体现。希望你能明白我的意思。
Self-doubt when uncontained causes us to unconsciously limit ourselves and limit our potential by letting sometimes life-changing opportunities pass us by and not acting because we can't possibly think that they'd be for somebody like us. The other way that this manifests is in indecisiveness, which some people would actually argue is a form of self-sabotage or a form of self-handicapping, an unconscious form of that. You know, indecisiveness involves very much overthinking and over-analyzing our decisions before we make them, perhaps to the point that we never do. Obviously, it's a good thing to think through your decisions. It's good to have some healthy level of skepticism and humility. otherwise we do veer too far into the path of arrogance.
如果不加以控制，自我怀疑会让我们在潜意识里限制自己和我们的潜力，让有时能改变一命的机会从我们身边溜走，因为我们不敢想象这些机会会属于像我们这样的人，从而选择按兵不动。这种心态的另一种表现形式是优柔寡断，有些人甚至会认为这是一种自我破坏或自我设障的形式，一种潜意识里的形式。你知道的，优柔寡断包含着在我们做出决定之前的过度思考和过度分析，甚至可能达到让我们永远无法做出决定的地步。很显然，仔细思考你的决定是一件好事。保持一定程度的健康怀疑精神和谦逊是好的，否则我们就会走向傲慢的极端。
But if we are actually just scared to fail, or if we are actually just scared of making the wrong decision because we don't trust our ability to meet the demands of this new chapter or this new opportunity, we are actually self-abandoning before we even gave ourselves a chance. And it's devastating that we are the ones who said no through our indecisiveness before anybody else could. we were our kind of biggest enemies in those moments without perhaps even realizing it.
但如果我们其实只是害怕失败，或者如果我们只是害怕做出错误的决定，因为我们不相信自己有能力应对新篇章或新机遇的要求，那么我们实际上是在还没给自己一个机会之前就自我放弃了。最让人痛心的是，在任何人开口之前，是我们通过自己的优柔寡断率先说出了“不”。在那些时刻，我们不知不觉中成为了自己最大的敌人。
Because in our mind, we were just trying to make the right decision. We were just trying to really weigh up all the pros and cons. But actually that analysis paralysis is a way of making sure that we never have to push past the discomfort of proving our self-doubts wrong. It's interesting because people might call. these kinds of individuals lazy or we might, you know, call them procrastinators. Because at face value, maybe that's what it looks like. But underneath it all is this belief system that has become rotten by insecurity that is invisible to everyone around us. And is, you know, the voice of that is our inner critic. The voice of that is this very loud, nagging sound in our head of like,
因为在我们的脑海里，我们只是想做出正确的决定。我们只是想认真权衡所有的利弊。但实际上，这种分析瘫痪是一种确保我们永远不必去克服那些证明自我怀疑是错误的痛苦的方式。有趣的是，人们可能会把这类人称为懒惰，或者我们可能会称他们为主张拖延的人。因为从表面上看，也许事实确实如此。但在这一切的背后，是一套被不安全感侵蚀得面目全非的信仰体系，它对我们周围的人来说是隐形的。你知道的，它的声音就是我们的内在批判者。它的声音是我们脑海中非常响亮、喋喋不休的声音，比如：
you can't do that. You're not good enough. Imagine every. that could go wrong. Imagine when somebody important is going to realize that you've lied, that you're a fraud, that you can't perform. Knowing what this may be costing us, you know, our dream life, a rich life, love, friendship, money, opportunities. What do we do about it? How do we silence that voice, that inner critic, that self-doubt? I have so many tips for you. So many tips coming up, including the power of a persona, the power of an alter ego,
你做不到。你不够优秀。想象一下所有可能出错的事情。想象一下当某个重要人物意识到你撒了谎、你是个骗子、你根本无法胜任时的情景。既然知道了这可能会让我们付出代价——我们的梦想生活、富足的生活、爱情、友情、金钱、机遇——我们该怎么办？我们如何才能让那个声音、那个内在的批判者、那个自我怀疑的声音闭嘴？我有很多建议要送给你。接下来会有很多建议，包括人格的力量、另一个自我的力量，
why we need exposure to failure and why we should be doubting our self-doubts. All of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
为什么我们需要承受失败的历练，以及为什么我们应该怀疑自己的自我怀疑。所有这些以及更多精彩内容，就在这段简短的广告之后。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在光怪陆离的现代世界中培养精神坚韧度、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带你穿透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上会引起发炎。我们弄错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的“TWO%”。还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击了小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here. unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill,
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes.
大谈80年代的快克可卡因。坦白说，84对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都可以聊快克，不过为了让大家知道我的意思。我是说，马克，到了这个时候，这已经是我们第二期讨论快克了，所以我开始看出一条贯穿始终的线索了。我们现在甚至连艾滋病都摆上台面了，所以。谢谢你把话说完。是的。
I don't think there's a more important year for black. people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
我不认为还有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person
以至于我们没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐；我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们总是盯着生活记分牌，生活变成了输赢的游戏史蒂夫·布恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯因为你觉得在这里活着时做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人只是因为你害怕？因为这是两种完全不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的，这是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，进行关于疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。
while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她言辞中明显的前后矛盾。由此开启了一场长达数年的法庭之争，旨在证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支网络侦探大队来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的税收被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的天啊。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，新闻报道称，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, news, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at
劳拉·欧文斯已被正式指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。明知自己对负面自我怀疑有一回事，我认为解决它们完全是另一回事，因为我们基本上现在背负着重塑整个信念体系的任务。证据告诉我们，这个体系已经存在了多年，可能比我们意识到它的时间还要长。因此，让我们来剖析一下如何才能重新掌控你的自我怀疑。首先，深入挖掘你的负面想法和负面自我信念，问问自己：你究竟在害怕什么？你的
Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Knowing that we have negative doubts about ourselves is one thing. I think addressing them is a whole other base because we are essentially. now tasked with undoing a whole belief system, one which, you know, the evidence would tell us has been around for many, many years, probably longer than we have been aware of it. So let's break down how we can kind of regain control over your self-doubt. Firstly, really go behind your negative thoughts and your negative self-beliefs and ask, what are you actually afraid of? What are
自我怀疑究竟在警告你什么？它们在保护你免受什么伤害？这种恐惧究竟想告诉你什么？正如我们之前所说，自我怀疑其实是一种自我保护的形式。它在说：“你知道的，这种境遇下的失败很可怕。评判很可怕。我们不想暴露在那种风险中，所以我们还是稳妥一点吧。”我想让你做的是，对听从这些自我怀疑并带着恐惧生活，还是不顾恐惧生活，做一个类似利弊分析的事情。我举个例子。假设你正在考虑搬到一个新的城市，但你在过去的六个月里一直举棋不定。你在怀疑自己：“我能一个人搞定这一切吗？
your doubts supposedly warning you of? What are they protecting you from? What is this fear trying to tell you? Like we said before, you know, self-doubt is a form of self-protection. It's saying, you know, failure in this circumstance is scary. Judgment is scary. And we don't want to be exposed to that, so let's play it safe. And what I want you to do is almost like a pro-con analysis of what it would mean to listen to those self-doubts and live with the fear or to live in spite of it. Let me give you an example. Say you are thinking of moving it to a new city, but you've been going back and forth on it for the last six months. You're doubting yourself, you know, can I do this alone?
我是那种能做这种事的人吗？我会在六个月后灰头土脸地回来，承认我失败了吗？承认我找不到工作、无法适应、无法结交新朋友？别人会怎么看我？”有时你觉得自己能行，有时又觉得不行。你经历了自信心的断崖式下跌。于是你搁置了做决定。但你觉得自己似乎在做点什么，因为你一直在分析并试图
Am I the kind of person who does these things? Will I have to return in six months and admit that I failed, that I couldn't find a job, that I couldn't adapt, that I couldn't make new friends? What are people going to think of me? Some days you think you can do it and other days you don't think you can. You experience that really awful drop in self-confidence. And so you hold off making the decision. But you feel like you're doing something because you're constantly analyzing and trying
从根本上确定：我是否有足够的信念来做这件事？你真正害怕的、助长这种自我怀疑的东西可能要复杂得多。你不仅害怕失败，你还害怕别人的看法。你害怕向自己证明自己无能。你害怕孤独。你害怕自己承受巨变和不确定性的能力。但是，不确定性、孤独、巨变或过渡期，对你造成的最大打击到底能有多大？真的。你会感到不舒服，是的，但你也不会成长。这可能会很艰难。这需要勇气，但在一年之后，
to essentially determine, do I believe in myself enough to do this? What you might actually be afraid of, what might be fueling this self-doubt is actually more complex. You're not just scared of failing, but you are scared. of what others think. You're scared of proving to yourself that you're not capable. You're scared of loneliness. You're scared of your ability to tolerate change and uncertainty. But what is the worst thing that uncertainty or loneliness or change or transition can really do to you? Truly. You'll feel uncomfortable, yes, but you also won't grow. It might be hard. It will take courage, but in a year's time,
你会回首过往并心想：“我真庆幸自己当初做了这个决定。”那些记忆将会历久弥新。当你真正去探究自我怀疑的根源，去寻找你为什么质疑自己做某事能力的背后原因时，当你审视支撑这种信念的恐惧时，你会发现：你的自我怀疑试图保护你免受的伤害，其实并不如它阻止你去做的事那般可怕——如果这么说你能理解的话。工作或大学里职业生涯中的事情也是如此。你究竟在害怕什么？通过不去争取那个晋升机会、不去申请那份工作、不去开启你自己的事业或创造新的东西、不去展现自己，你的自我怀疑究竟在试图保护你免受什么？是尴尬吗？是害怕被别人看到和感知吗？
you'll look back and think, I'm so glad that I did this now. And those memories are going to last for a long time. When you actually go behind your self-doubt, behind why you question your ability to do something, and you look at what fears are holding up that belief, you realize that what your self-doubt is trying to protect you from is not as scary as what it is protecting you from not doing, if that makes sense. The same goes for things at work or at uni professionally in your career. What do you actually afraid of? What are your self-doubts trying to protect you from by not going for that promotion, by not applying for that job, by not, you know, starting your own business or creating something new or putting yourself out there? Is it embarrassment? Is it being seen and perceived by others?
是失败吗？是向自己证明你一直以来的想法——即你根本不配拥有这一切吗？再次强调，首先，这些恐惧在99%的情况下是不会发生的。你不会让自己出丑。你不会以一种会伤害到你的负面方式被他人看待。但即使它们真的发生了，难道比从未尝试过更糟吗？一件糟糕事情发生的潜在恐惧，真的抵得上一个极其美好机遇带来的价值吗？顺便说一句，这在实践中可能很难做到。我完全理解。但我采用的方法之一，就是将我的自我怀疑人格化，并带着同情和感激直接与它对话。我知道这听起来很傻，但试一试吧。对你的自我怀疑说：
Is it failure? Is it proving to yourself what you always thought that you don't deserve it anyways? Again, firstly, those fears are probably 99% of the time not going to happen. You're not going to embarrass yourself. You're not going to be perceived by others in a negative way that it's going to harm you. But if they do, is it worse than never trying at all? Is the fear of the possibility of something bad happening worth the opportunity of something really good happening? That can be hard to put into practice, by the way. I absolutely understand. But one of the ways that I do it is by personifying my self-doubt and speaking directly to it with compassion and gratitude. I know this sounds really silly, but just try it. Say to yourself doubt like,
“嘿，我真的很感激你照顾我。你太好了。非常感谢你预料到这些事情。我真的很感激你所做的所有额外工作，不过接下来就交给我吧。无论如何我都要去做，我们以后可以再复盘。我们回头再聊。”要记住的一点是，你就是你的自我怀疑。它们属于你。它们源自于你。所以你也可以对它们说“不”。你可以说：“不，其实我不这么认为。抱歉。事实上，不，那可能不会发生。所以谢谢你的这个想法。你错了。我们继续。”另一件真正能帮我理清头绪、让我正确看待事物的事情是，提醒自己其他人——那些我崇拜的人——
hey, I really appreciate you looking out for me. That is so nice of you. Thank you so much for anticipating those things. I really appreciate all the extra work that you're doing, but I've got it from here. I'm going to do it anyways and we can revisit later on. We'll circle back. The thing to remember is that you are your self-doubts. You own them. They come from you. And so you can say no to them as well. You can say, yeah, no, I actually don't believe that. Sorry. Actually, no, like, that's probably not going to happen. So thank you for that thought. You're wrong. Moving on. The other thing that really helps me with this and helps me put things into perspective is to remind myself that other people, people that I admire,
其实也和我一样，有着同样的内心自我怀疑和不确定感。我们很容易拿自己与身边的人、这些非常成功的人进行比较，并且会天真地认为，他们之所以拥有我们梦想的一切，唯一原因就是他们对自己的能力始终充满自信，或者一切对他们而言都顺风顺水，他们完全没有这些自我怀疑。但实际上，许多伟人、许多我们真正崇拜的人，都经历过挫折。他们经历过毁灭性的怀疑，必须克服这些怀疑才能成为今天的自己。每当谈到这一点，我脑海中总是浮现出西蒙娜·拜尔斯。奥运会马上就要到了。她就是一个很好的例子。她是获得奖牌最多的体操运动员，
pretty much have the same internal self-scepticism and doubts as me. It's very easy to compare ourselves to the people around us, these incredibly successful people, and kind of believe that the only reason they have what we dream of is because they were always confident in their ability to do so, or that everything has worked out for them, that they have none of these self-doubts when actually so many of the greats, so many of the people we really admire, have had setbacks. They have had crippling doubts that they have had to overcome to be who they are now. The person I always think of when it comes to this is Simone Biles. The Olympics are coming up. She's a great example. She's the most decorated gymnast,
是历史上成就最高的奥运选手之一。几年前，她在接受采访时说，有很多次她觉得自己不够优秀，她对自己的表现吹毛求疵，用她的话说，她甚至记不起有哪一天是没有哭过的。我们每个人带着怀疑去面对自己的梦想、渴望和计划。即使是那些你绝不会相信会动摇、哪怕一秒钟也不会觉得自己不够伟大的人，因为他们就是最棒的。然而，冒名顶替综合症依然会击垮他们。这就像是一种天然的均势器。当你意识到甚至这些不可思议的运动员、不可思议的人也有这种感受时，你也开始意识到，也许他们和那些未能站上领奖台的人之间唯一的区别，
one of the most accomplished Olympians in history. And a few years back, she gave this interview saying that there had been so many times when she didn't think that she was good enough, when she was so hypercritical of her performance that, in her words, she couldn't remember a day where she didn't cry. We each come to our dreams and our desires and our plans with doubts. Even those who you would never believe would falter or for one second think that they weren't great because they are the best. Imposter syndrome still strikes them down. It's like the natural equalizer. And when you realize that even these incredible athletes, incredible people have these feelings, you also begin to realize that maybe the only difference between them and maybe the
也许我们之间的区别在于，他们没有让潜藏在自我怀疑根源处的恐惧压倒自己。这就是为什么我认为拥有这种现实的偶像、看到这些例子并听他们谈论这些会对抚慰我们的自我怀疑如此有帮助的另一个原因，它真的能帮我们问出这样的问题：“为什么不能是我？为什么我不能拥有那个？为什么我不能成为她？为什么我不能心怀大志，或者去抓住他们曾抓住过的机会？”因为我们也有同样的自我怀疑。
people who aren't on that podium, maybe us, is that they didn't let that fear at the root of their self-doubt overwhelm them. Here is the other reason why I think having these kinds of realistic idols and seeing these examples and hearing them speak about it is so helpful for soothing our self-doubts, it really helps us ask the question, you know, why not me? Why can't I have that? Why can't I be her? Why can't I dream big or take the chances that they have? Because we have the same self-doubts.
他们只是为这些自我怀疑找到了一个安放之处。他们树立了榜样。他们证明了这是可能的。现在轮到你了。也许你不想成为一名奥运体操运动员，但是，无论你正在为什么而奋斗，在你的职业领域里，总有这样一个人榜样，他曾经历过最毁灭性的自我怀疑，却依然超越了它。我希望我们能坐下来静静地思考一下这个问题。
They've just found a place for them. They've set the example. They have proven that it's possible. And now it's kind of your turn. Maybe you don't want to be an Olympic gymnast, but, you know, whatever it is that you are striving towards, there is an example of somebody in that professional in your career who has experienced the most crippling form of self-doubt and pushed beyond it. And I want us to just sit for a second and really ponder that question.
无论是什么让你的自我怀疑停滞不前，为什么不能是你？我希望你能给我至少三个理由。大概率你给不出来，因为你的恐惧和自我怀疑根本不合逻辑。它只是在赌你会盲目地听从它，
Whatever it is that your self-doubt is keeping you back from, why not you? And I want you to give me at least three reasons. Chances are you can't because your fear and your self-doubt is not actually rational. It's just kind of betting on you listening to it blindly. and obeying what it's telling you to do, being indecisive, it's betting on you not taking risks, it's betting on you playing it safe. When actually, when you really drill down into it, the reasons to not do something are often a lot less persuasive than the reasons to do something.
顺从它的指使去优柔寡断；它在赌你不敢冒险，赌你会求稳。而实际上，当你真正深入剖析时，不做某事的理由往往远不如去做某事的理由那么具有说服力。
Here's how we counteract that. Make a persona for yourself, create a version of you, visualize a character that would do all the things that you believe that you can't. base that persona off of the people you admire who did what you dream to do, even if they're fictional, base that persona off of your ideal vision of your future self or your idols or your wildest dreams and give them a name. And then the question is between doubting yourself and doing the thing, whatever it is, ask yourself, okay, what would my persona do?
我们如何反击呢？为自己打造一个人物设定，创造一个版本的自己，构想一个角色，让他去做所有你认为自己做不到的事情。将这个人物设定建立在你所崇拜、实现了你梦想之人（哪怕他们是虚构的）的基础之上；将这个人物设定建立在你对未来自己的理想愿景、你的偶像或你最大胆的梦想之上，并给他们起个名字。然后，在自我怀疑和付诸行动之间——无论那是什么——问问自己：好吧，我的这个人设会怎么做？
What would this version of me who is everything I want to be, who is all the great parts of everybody else that I love and I admire, would they take the risk? You know, they wouldn't think twice. Would they put themselves out there? Of course they would. Would they wear this weird outfit? Of course they would. And there you go. They are the justification for doing all the things that you maybe wouldn't do otherwise. Be like, you know, well, I wasn't going to take that solo trip, but Patricia, my alter ego made me. She wanted me to go. So I guess I have to go. I wasn't going to apply for that promotion or ask that person out. but, you know, Ronaldo would do it. And I've got to, you know, do it for Ronaldo.
这个版本的我会怎么做？她拥有我渴望成为的一切，汇聚了我所爱和崇拜的所有人的优点，她会冒险吗？你知道的，她不会多想。她会把真实的自己展现出来吗？当然会。她会穿这件奇怪的衣服吗？当然会。你看，这就是了。他们就是你去做那些平时可能不敢做的事情的正当理由。你可以说：“嗯，我本来不打算独自旅行的，但帕特里夏——我的另一个自我逼我去的。她想让我去。所以我想我只能去了。”我本来不打算申请那个晋升或者向那个人表白的，但是，你知道的，罗纳尔多会这么做。为了罗纳尔多，我必须去做。
I've got to do it for this alter ego. I've got to be this version and vision of me that I believe in and that is possible. Become that persona, become this alter ego. You know, make them responsible for the things that you are scared to do. The benefits of this are amazing. Greater performance, greater confidence, more willpower, quicker decision making. In psychology, it's called the Batman effect. reason it works is because it allows us to separate ourselves from all the negative beliefs,
我必须为了这个另一个自我去尝试。我必须成为这个我相信、并且切实可行的版本的自己。去成为那个人设，去成为这个另一个自我。你知道的，让他们为你那些不敢做的事情负责。这样做的好处是惊人的：更出色的表现、更强的自信、更强的意志力、更果断的决策。在心理学中，这被称为“蝙蝠侠效应”。它之所以管用，是因为它能让我们将自己与所有的负面信念隔离开来，
our past, our memories, whatever is holding us back. And it projects only the best parts of ourselves onto this, you know, I don't want to say false, this fantasy version of us. It kind of reigns in the undesirable feelings that are holding us back through this very effective form of self-distancing. When I want to stop getting in my own way, I think about what Gemma with a G would do. She wouldn't think about others' opinions before her own. Gemma with the G is totally confident, totally self-aware. She wouldn't doubt herself before she expressed what she was feeling.
我们的过去、我们的记忆、任何阻碍我们前进的东西。它只把我们身上最好的一部分投射到这个（我不想说是虚假的）幻想版本的我们身上。它通过这种非常有效的自我疏离形式，将那些阻碍我们前进的不良情绪收归管束。当我想停止自我阻碍时，我会想：名字带G的杰玛会怎么做？她绝不会把别人的意见置于自己的意见之前。名字带G的杰玛极其自信，有着高度的自我觉察。她在表达自己的感受之前绝不会自我怀疑。
She wouldn't stop herself saying yes to cool things or going places where she knew no one. That's what Gemma with a G would do. And I want to do right by her. So try this persona alter ego tip for just a week. Apply it where necessary and see if it changes anything. think it's almost like thinking from a place of your ideal self rather than your scared self rather than your doubting self. If your self doubt is especially linked to procrastination and indecisiveness, I would also say train yourself to not do things perfectly every time. Treat failure like an
她绝不会阻止自己对酷炫的事情说““好””，或者去那些她一个人都不认识的地方。这就是名字带G的杰玛会做的事。我想向她看齐。所以，请尝试这个“人格/另一个自我”的小建议，坚持哪怕一个星期。在需要的时候运用它，看看它是否能改变什么。我认为这几乎就像是以你理想中的自我而非恐惧中的自我、而非怀疑中的自我的视角来思考。如果你的自我怀疑特别与拖延和优柔寡断有关，我还要建议你：训练自己不要每次都把事情做到完美。对待失败就像对待
assignment almost and just do. Go to the gym even if you don't end up working out, right? You still went, you still made a decision to go. Wear an outfit even if you. you know it doesn't look great just for like a couple of hours. Put your hand up to host that event or to go to that run club or anything that means you will show up even if you don't show up perfectly because what matters most is just being decisive and doing. That is what we are trying to train ourselves into. You are allowed to make mistakes.
作业一样，直接去做。去健身房，哪怕你最后并没有真正锻炼，对吧？你还是去了，你还是做出了去的决定。穿上一套衣服，哪怕你明知它看起来并不那么出彩，哪怕只穿几个小时。举手争取主持那个活动，或者参加那个跑步俱乐部，或者做任何意味着你能“到场”的事情——哪怕你到场时的表现并不完美——因为最重要的是果断和行动。这正是我们努力训练自己去达到的状态。你允许犯错。
You don't have to do it perfectly. That's okay. And you build up this tolerance for failure and failure is often the thing that our self-doubt is most scared of. It's like when you do cold water plunges, right? It feels so terrible at the beginning, but soon you begin to relax into it and realize that this actually isn't that scary. This actually isn't dangerous.
你不需要把它做到完美。没关系的。你要建立起对失败的耐受力，而失败往往正是我们的自我怀疑最害怕的东西。这就好比你去做冷水浴，对吧？一开始感觉糟透了，但很快你就会开始放松下来，意识到这其实并没那么可怕。这其实一点也不危险。
My brain is just trying to convince me that it is to protect me. This also doesn't give us time to get stuck in the analysis loop of do I do it, do I not, am I deserving, am I not? Because our assignment is to disregard those things and just do. It's that simple. Make it that simple. Just do it. Oh my God.
我的大脑只是为了保护我而试图说服我它很危险。这也让我们没有时间陷入“我该做还是不该做？我配还是不配？”的分析循环中。因为我们的任务就是无视这些杂念，直接去做。就是这么简单。让它变得如此简单。Just do it（放手去做）。天哪。
Hopefully I don't get sued by. Nike for using their phrase that was completely accidental. But again, ask the question, what are you truly afraid of? Get behind those fears. And is there a chance that your doubts are incorrect? That is the final part of this. My final tip for this episode, question what your brain is trying to convince you is fact. And remember that if your doubts came from you, there is a possibility that they might be biased or maybe wrong. A lot of the time they are based on this incorrect or faulty evidence. You know, this faulty evidence from our past experiences that incorrectly made us assume that
希望我不会因为用了耐克的那句口号而被起诉，那纯属巧合。但再次强调，问问自己：你究竟在害怕什么？去探究那些恐惧背后的原因。你的怀疑有没有可能是错的？这是最后一部分。我这一集的最后一条建议是：质疑你的大脑试图让你相信是“事实”的东西。记住，既然你的怀疑源自你自己，它们就完全有可能带有偏见甚至是错误的。很多时候，它们是基于这些错误或有缺陷的证据。你知道的，来自我们过去经验的这些有缺陷的证据，错误地让我们以为
we weren't worthy, we weren't valuable, we weren't talented, we weren't intelligent. And because those doubts are actually originating from inside of you, they have an internal origin. Once again, you can choose to say, yeah, you know, I don't think that's right. I'm just going to choose to not believe this today. I'm going to choose to not believe that I don't deserve this. I'm going to believe that there wasn't a mistake, that I didn't just get lucky, that I'm here for a reason, because that belief and my self-doubt are both coming from me and they
我们不配、我们没有价值、我们没有天赋、我们不够聪明。正因为这些怀疑实际上源于你的内心，它们有着内在的根源。再说一次，你可以选择说：“是的，你知道吗，我觉得那不对。我今天就是选择不相信这个。我选择不相信自己不配拥有这一切。我相信那不是个错误，我不仅仅是运气好，我来到这里是有原因的。”因为这种信念和我的自我怀疑都来自于我，它们
both have the capacity to be true. So I'm going to do it anyways. I'm going to be myself anyways. I'm going to show up anyways. Some final reminders, because you know I love to click. my episodes out with a little pep talk to hype you guys up to get you to apply what I'm hoping you've learned. Please remember that most of us don't just explode right out the gate. Most of us do spend some time doubting our own abilities in some capacity. The difference is whether you let that
都有可能是真的。所以我不管怎样都要去做。我无论如何都要做自己。无论如何我都要全力以赴。一些最后的提醒，因为你们知道我喜欢用一点心灵鸡汤来结束我的节目，给你们打打气，让你们去践行我希望你们学到的东西。请记住，我们大多数人并不是一开始就能一飞冲天的。我们大多数人都曾在某种程度上花时间怀疑过自己的能力。区别在于，你是让这种怀疑
define your reality or you let it just be a thought. It can be hard when your inner critic is loud, but once again, your inner critic is your own voice. You and your inner critic, you and your inner critic, critic are one and the same. So you are actually able to replace those beliefs with a better and more real understanding of who you are, which is someone who is competent, confident, a risk taker willing to bet on themselves, someone who learns from setbacks and who, if you've made it this far, is obviously deeply committed to becoming your best self. So don't let yourself be to blame for, I guess, holding you back. Don't, you know, get to the end of your life and realize that nobody ever actually said no or turned you away or turned you down. You did it before they even had the
定义了你的现实，还是仅仅把它当成一个想法。当你的内在批判者声音很大时，这可能会很难，但再说一次，你的内在批判者就是你自己的声音。你和你的内在批判者，你和你的内在批判者其实是同一个人。所以你完全有能力用对你是谁的更好、更真实的理解来取代那些信念——你是一个有能力、自信、敢于冒险、愿意押注自己的人，是一个从挫折中吸取教训的人，而且，如果你能听到这里，你显然对成为最好的自己有着深深的执着。所以，别让自己成为阻碍你前进的罪魁祸首。别让你的生命走到尽头时才意识到，其实从来没有人对你说过“不”或把你拒之门外。是你抢在他们之前对自己说了“不”。所以你从来没有真正把自己
chance. So you never really, you know, put yourself in the running. I don't want that to be your reality. So I'm giving you a big hug through the microphone and a big, you can fucking do it because you can, you absolutely can. Your self-doubts do not control you. And as always, I just really hope that you, enjoyed this episode. At the least, I hope that you learned something new about yourself, about your life, or about your psychology. As always, if you feel like there is somebody in your life who could benefit from this, please feel free to share it with them. Make sure that you are following along for new episodes. I'm just going to say, we've got some amazing ones coming out soon. I am so excited for next week's episode in particular. Maybe it's already out by the time you're
放入赛道中。我不希望那是你的现实。所以我通过麦克风给你一个大大的拥抱，还有一个大大的“你特么一定能行”，因为你真的可以，你绝对可以。你的自我怀疑无法控制你。一如既往，我真的希望你们能享受这一集。至少，我希望你们对自己、对生活或对心理学有了新的认识。一如既往，如果你觉得你生活中的某个人能从中受益，请随时分享给他们。确保关注我们的新节目，随时获取更新。我要说的是，我们很快就会推出一些精彩绝伦的节目。我特别为下周的节目感到兴奋。也许当你听到这里时它已经上线了，如果是这样的话，那就去听那一集吧。如果你能在Apple Podcasts或Spotify上给我们一个五星好评，那也将对节目的成长和触达新受众提供巨大的帮助。如果你喜欢这一集，如果你有反馈，更重要的是，如果你有话题建议——关于20多岁心理学中我们尚未涵盖的内容——我很乐意听到你的声音。确保关注That Psychology Podcast，或者你也可以关注我@Jemisbeg。直到下次，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点，我们很快再聊。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听的是由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯带来的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行那些
listening to this, but listen to that one next, if that is the case. And if you could give us a five-star review on Apple Podcasts or Spotify, that also really helps the show to grow and reach a new audience. If you enjoyed this episode, if you have feedback, and more importantly, if you have a topic suggestion, something about the psychology of your 20s that we have not yet covered, I would love to hear from you. Make sure that you are following along at that psychology podcast, or you can follow me at Jemisbeg and until next time be safe be kind be gentle to yourself and we will talk soon hey what's good y'all you're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host care games this space is about black men's experiences having honest conversations that's really not safe
除了这里之外在别处根本无法进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的有执照的专业人士交流。有多少男人身披重铠？它向世界发出信号：你是不好惹的。但仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听并了解《Learn the Hard Way》。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，
to have anywhere but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing how many men carry a suit or armor it signals to the world that you're not to be played with and just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%.
我将剖析我们在光怪陆离的现代世界中培养精神坚韧度、体能和抗压能力的科学。经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的“TWO%”。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target.
他休想逃脱惩罚。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。我懂你。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I got you.
在《Look Back at It》播客中。1979年，那对我来说是个重大时刻。84对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。
On the Look Back at it podcast. 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
与我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那是个疯狂的年份。我不认为还有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。这是一档iHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击转写文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家们一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。确实是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在iHeart广播应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。这是一个iHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。